♪ ♪
>> I WILL SAY IN ORDER TO MAKE
IT WORK, HE WE NEED METH
STABILIZATION CENTER IN
PORTLAND, WE NEED THEM WHEN THEY
ARE IN A METH RELATED PSYCHOSIS.
>> Laura: FORGET PORTLAND, DO
THEY NEED A METH STABILIZATION
CENTER?
THAT WAS OREGON DEMOCRATIC
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE TALKING
ABOUT TO MEASURE 110, WHICH
DECRIMINALIZED HARD DRUGS LIKE,
HEROIN, LSD, AND COCAINE.
WANT TO SHOW YOU WHAT EFFECT
THAT HAD STATEWIDE.
THESE ARE OVERDOSE DEATHS IN
OREGON.
2021 MEASURE 110 WAS ON THE
BALLOT AND THEN APPROVED IN
NOVEMBER.
YELLOW IS 2021 AFTER IT WENT
INTO EFFECT TO THAT FEBRUARY.
AND GREENE IS 2022 SO FAR.
OVERDOSE DEATHS INCREASED NEARLY
50 PERCENT FROM 2020 TO 2021.
DOES NOT TAKE A MATH GENIUS TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
JOINING ME NOW IS CHRISTINE
GILES INCOME OF THE REPUBLICAN
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR IN OREGON,
ALL RIGHT, THE RCB AVERAGE HAS
HER AT 2.4% AHEAD IN A STATE
THAT HAS NOT ELECTED A
REPUBLICAN IN 40 YEARS, I LOVE
THIS, CHRISTINE, WHAT WILL THIS
METH STABILIZATION CENTER
ACCOMPLISH?
IS THERE ANY GOOD?
>> YOU KNOW, THIS IS A
CONTINUATION OF THE FIELD
LEADERSHIP, SHE IS OUT OF TOUCH
WITH OREGONIANS, MAKING CHOICES
OF MAKING DECISIONS THAT ARE
JUST POLITICALLY DRIVEN, THE
REALITY ON THE GROUND IS THAT
DRUGS HARM FAMILY IS.
AND DRUGS ARE HURTING OUR STATE,
THEY ARE HURTING OUR COMMUNITY,
AND FRANKLY AS YOU NOTED, PEOPLE
ARE DYING.
THE ANSWER HERE IS NOT TO
CONTINUE TO ENABLE THIS
BEHAVIOR, THE ANSWER IS TO GET
PEOPLE INTO TREATMENT AND
LONG-TERM RECOVERY AND NOT TO
ASSUME THAT THIS IS HOW OUR
STATE HAS TO BE LONG-TERM AND
THEREFORE WE NEED TO CREATE METH
STABILIZATION CENTERS, THAT IS
THE WRONG ANSWER.
SPEED LIMIT XP TO I WANT PEOPLE
TO SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
CRIME IN PORTLAND, AND THEN
AGAIN, EVERYONE WHO KNOWS
PORTLAND AND WHO HAS BEEN THERE
OVER THE LAST 20 OR 25 YEARS, IT
IS A BEAUTIFUL CITY.
BUT IT HAS CHANGED DRAMATICALLY.
AND SO CRIME LARGELY REMAINED
STEADY IN 2021, BUT PORTLAND
SHOT UP DRAMATICALLY, THE NUMBER
OF VIOLENT CRIMES IN PORTLAND
INCREASED 38%, THAT INCLUDED
HOMICIDES, RAPES ROBBERIES AND
AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS, ALL HAVE
BEEN MORE IN 2021 THEN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR, CHRISTINE, YOUR
RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> WE NEED MORE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ON THE STREETS.
AND FRANKLY, WE NEED TO GOVERNOR
THAT IS NOT GOING TO ENGAGE IN
THE MASS RELEASE OF CRIMINALS.
THAT'S WHAT KATE BROWN HAS DONE.
THAT'S WHAT TINA COMPANY TECH
ALIGNS WITH KATE BROWN TO
CONTINUE TO JUST RELEASE AND
MURDERERS ONTO HER STREET.
AS GOVERNOR I WILL SUPPORT
VICTIMS.
WE HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT ON OUR
STREETS AND THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE SAFE.
>> Laura: THERE ARE OVER 200
POLICE OFFICERS AS A DEFICIT
RIGHT NOW IN PORTLAND, IS THAT
ACCURATE?
WOULD YOU DO TO TRY TO BRING
MORE INTO THE FOREST?
>> Laura: IT IS ACCURATE.
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT NEED A
GOVERNOR THAT IS GOING TO BACK
THERE PLAY, AND FOR TOO LONG
PARTICULARLY IN PORTLAND, THEY
KNOW THAT THE CRITICAL
LEADERSHIP IN THAT COMMUNITY HAS
NOT SUPPORTED THEM AND THE FOUR
PEOPLE LIVING IN PORTLAND HAS
BEEN THAT THEY FEEL LESS SAFE,
LESS OFFICERS ON THE ROAD, SO
RESPONSE TIMES ARE LOWER, AND
IT'S NOT THEIR FAULT, THEY ARE
OVERWHELMED.
THEY NEED AN AGGRESSIVE PUSH
THAT SAYS WE WANT
LAW ENFORCEMENT HERE, PLEASE
COME TO OUR COMMUNITY, WE WILL
SUPPORT YOU AND WE KNOW THAT WE
NEED YOU.
>> Laura: I THINK THAT THEY
SUPPORTED THE RIOTERS OVER THE
POLICE IN 2020 WHEN THAT WHOLE
PLACE IS BEING RIPPED APART,
CORRECT?
>> Laura: ABSOLUTELY AND
ABSOLUTELY THE WRONG DECISION
AGAIN, FAILED LEADERSHIP ONE